[Musique]
bien alors moi je vais vous parler
d'europe
moi je vous demande et ne pas dormir ce
généralement quand on parle d'europe
pour trouve que c'est ennuyeux
rébarbatif si vous cherchez si vous
écrivez les livres sur l'europe
contrairement à mes petites copines qui
sont passés tout à l'heure vous
trouverez pas d'éditeur il y à il ya une
émission de télé ou des candidats qui
ont vocation devenir président de la
république devait parler d'europe ils
ont préféré se chamailler dont on va
parler d'europe
ben moi je vais vous parler d'europe
parce que j'ai une petite histoire à
nous raconter et elle est pas mal
alors c'est vrai que l'europe quand on
la prend comme ça en ce moment on se dit
que les nouvelles sont pas très bonnes
les anglais j'ai bien dit les anglais
allaient britannique
les anglais veulent nous quitter les
hongrois qui rêve d'une grande hongrie
ont rien trouvé de mieux que de mettre
des clôtures on croyait que ça avait
disparu après la chute du mur pour se
protéger de l'invasion migratoire
on a les wallons et voilons qui ont fait
une crise d'urticaire avant l'heure à
l'idée de manger du steak d'orignal
canadien pour finalement s'apercevoir et
passe ici jill est que ça et puis on à
la pologne qui s'est dotée d'un
gouvernement rétrograde qui veut
remettre en cause un certain nombre de
lois dont celle sur l'avortement
il ya là patatras les femmes toutes les
femmes polonaises sont descendus
massivement dans la rue et le
gouvernement il a pu les le projet de
loi a été abandonné parce que ma petite
histoire justement c'est que quand on
parle des femmes en europe les nouvelles
sont bien meilleurs parce que en europe
grâce à l'eau à la place des femmes dans
ce continent est la meilleure bon je
vais vous dire pourquoi
d'abord en europe c'est là qu'il ya le
plus de femmes dirigeants parmi les pays
qui gêne vous citez le royaume uni et la
pologne
ces deux exemples de pays qui sont
dirigées par des femmes des oiseaux mais
bien d'un cyclo méline troisième que
vous connaissez beaucoup mieux
s'il est là au pouvoir depuis longtemps
douze ans qu'elle fait régulièrement la
une des magazines des journaux des
classements qui sont pas forcément
européen il ya des journaux américains
qui trouvent que c'est la femme l'appui
puissantes du monde
comment il s'appelle ouais en gala
merkel la chancelière allemande
3 et bien c'est pas beaucoup à 3 mais il
faut savoir aussi qu'il ya quatre
présidente de la république dans les
pays européens en lituanie en estonie
depuis un mois une jeune femme 46 ans
n'est ce pas ça m'ira en croatie et à
malte
et puis si on ajoute la norvège qui
n'est pas dans l'union européenne mais
quand même sur ce continent européen on
arrive à 8
vous me direz puisqu'elle raconte comme
histoire huit femmes
bah oui mais justement ces huit femmes
européennes chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement elles représentent autant
de femmes qui aiment femme présidente et
chef d'état le chef du gouvernement
ailleurs dans le monde elle invite aussi
mais elles sont réparties un peu en
afrique au chili en corée et et
peut-être peut-être une oreille neuvième
mardi
mais pour l'instant n'est pas réduite
donc il ya autant de femmes chez vettel
gouvernements en europe qu'il ya dans le
reste du monde ça c'est quand même pas
mal quand on regarde les institutions
européennes
alors c'est vrai ya pas de présidente il
y en a eu au parlement de 2 française
simone veil 79 et nicole fontaine depuis
que des hommes au conseil
c'est un peu récent il ya eu deux
titulaires pour l'instant deux hommes
puisqu'il ya une règle qui dit que le
tir du piqueur du poste doit être chef
de gouvernement
on va attendre un peu à la bce pour
l'instant il ya une femme au conseil des
gouverneurs c'est déjà pas mal mais la
commission européenne il ya 9 femmes sur
les 28 commissaire 9
c'est déjà le tiers si pas mal
et puis on leur a donné des postes très
importants
le budget les affaires étrangères mais
encore deux femmes plus importante que
ça parce qu'elle s'occupe de compétences
qui sont vraiment européenne
vous les connaissez et une grande femme
comme moi danoise madame margrethe
vestage heures et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
madame d'estag heures elle s'occupe de
la concurrence c'est à dire qu'elle
regarde ce qu'il faut toutes les
entreprises pour se conformer au droit
européen pas que les entreprises
européennes
tout est si je vous dis oui 3 non vous
allez viens oui c'est elle
mycroft google apple c'est elle qui est
en train de régler tout ça pourquoi en
effet il s'adapte au droit européen
et puis un deuxième je vous ai fait rire
avec mon histoire de rien à elle tout à
l'heure canadien c'est la personne qui
s'occupe du commerce le commerce est une
fonction qui est dédié à l'europe
la commissaire et une suédoise elle
s'occupe en effet de tous les accords de
libre échange que l'union qui je le
rappelle est la première puissance
commerciale et économique du monde sait
que quand on rejoint lé 28 pib dès lundi
déjà membres et bien le pib des 28es
supérieur à celui des etats unis
et bien voilà l'europe c'est ça c'est
pas et donc ces deux femmes elles ont
une particularité elles viennent du nord
de l'europe parce que mon deuxième point
c'est qu'en europe il ya un modèle qui
s'imposaient peu à peu c'est l'europe du
nord
parce que dans ces pays il ya une
tendance naturelle à répartir
équitablement le pouvoir entre les
hommes et les femmes et la suède est un
exemple très particulier parce que la
suède
fois le pays où il ya le plus de pâleur
de parlementaires femmes 45% et c'est
celui aussi où le gouvernement est
strictement paritaire 55 ans et la
petite surprise il ya un deuxième pays
qui arrive juste derrière vous le
connaissez il est trés géographiquement
proche de nous c'est la france dans le
gouvernement actuel il ya 50% de femmes
et 50% de gestion exemple que j'ai
trouvé pour caractériser la qualité
entre la entre les hommes et les femmes
en france puisque après ça se gâte un
peu
et puis c'est pas une tendance naturelle
il a fallu qu'on impose une loi la loi
sur la parité qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
pour être recevable une liche pas
comporter autant de femmes que d'hommes
de manière alternée pas les 13 premières
hommes et les 13 dernières femmes une
sur deux si bien qu'on laisse filer à 50
de femmes ont pu s'investir les conseils
municipaux dans les conseils
départementaux dans les conseils
régionaux à l'assemblée le scrutin
uninominal donc c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose
la graine 6% entre parlementaires si
bien qu'au sénat il ya plus de femmes
que d'hommes puisque eux et à un système
proportionnel qui fait qu'à plus de
sénatrice que des difficultés
et puis quand on regarde en effet
comment ça se passe dans l'exécutive ces
régions aux départements mairie alain on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes dans
les conseils départementaux vous avez
élu d'éthique et un homme une femme se
dit obligatoire donc à 50% des bus est
présidente
il y en a que 10 parce que c'est
difficile d'accéder au pouvoir encore
alors elles sont dans les conseils ne
sont pas dans l'exécuter et puis si
elles sont dans l'exécutif
c'est il ya un sens on a toutes chances
ou plus de chances de leur confier des
secteurs dits féminins l'éducation la
petite enfance les personnes âgées les
rarement la voirie l'urbanisme jean
michel on regarde et on a eu une
ministre des finances christine lagarde
on a eu une des ministres l'intérieur
des affaires étrangères et on a même
aujourd'hui en europe
cinq femmes ministres de la défense et
fonce un bastion quand même via masculin
donc en europe grâce à l'europe
et grâce à l'europe du nord les autres
pays ont fait progressivement monter
leur civilisation de parlement et de
nombreux parlementaires et donc en
europe aujourd'hui
si vous regardez une carte du monde mais
c'est laquelle plus de femmes
parlementaires alors c'est un tiers
c'est pas encore la parité mais en lait
devant les états unis
on est devant d'autres pays développés
on est devant l'asie a traversé et
l'afrique où ça ferait ce beau coup vous
allez me dire la politique
bon c'est un domaine particulier il faut
du temps s'investir c'est c'est pas
facile mais je vais venir au monde de
l'entreprise parce que en europe
c'est là aussi où elle peut donc le plus
grand nombre de femmes dans la
gouvernance des entreprises
là encore le modèle vient de l'europe du
nord la norvège en l'occurrence la
norvège a pris en 2004 une loi pour en
faire en sorte qu'en effet les femmes
puissent intégrer les conseils
d'administration des entreprises cotées
44 % aujourd'hui
si bien qu'à une petite imitation et
d'autres pays dont la france l'italie et
d'autres ont fait la même chose en
france c'est une loi qui en effet impose
à partir de là voire 40% de femmes et on
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure ça va être
effectif à partir l'année prochaine
donc on est deuxième avec les suédois
qui a eu encore une fois n'ont pas eu
besoin de loi a été naturel il ya 36 %
de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration suédois combien en
france mais tant qu'on regarde au niveau
mondial dans les dix premiers pays où
les femmes ya le plus d'administratrice
y en a sept qui sont repérés sur dix
fait normal après et à l'australie le
canada et israël
alors dès sur ses conseils
d'administration pour l'instant
symboliquement ça concerne les
entreprises cotées en france le cac 40
il a donc falloir qu'on continue pour
que ces femmes soient représentés dans
d'autres structures que en effet cette
parité qu'on a obligé un petit peu avec
la loi s'instaure dans d'autres
entreprises de plus petite taille celle
qui ne sont pas cotées au cac 40 mais
dans d'autres marchés voire dans les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire ou
des pme
et puis surtout parce que cette
promotion des femmes elle se fait pas
magiquement va falloir qu en effet cette
diversité cette mikli paix s'instaure
dans les instances internes de
gouvernance des entreprises
le comité exécutif où il ya en effet
beaucoup de suicides qui se prennent
alors en effet qu'on appose à peu près
la même règle ou les comités d'audit de
gestion de rémunération pour qu'en effet
on puisse repérer les talents féminins
très tôt les promouvoir et leur permette
d'accéder plus facilement au pouvoir
pour qu'elle évite d'avoir le plafond de
verre un peu trop rapidement et puis
quelque chose aussi en europe qui est
intéressant c'est le modèle social se
vexer l'économie sociale de marché le
modèle européen et le moc est important
là c'est le mot social parce que pour
permettre aux femmes de travailler il
faut aussi un peu les inciter à pouvoir
travailler alors il ya deux modèles il
ya des exemples qui viennent tout de
suite à l'esprit ya le congé maternité
monde sait ce que c'est en europe il est
plutôt favorable
l'appareil il ya des variantes mais
l'europe a fait en sorte que tous les
pays ont à peu près grosso modo
sensiblement la même chose mais une
petite particularité que j'aimerais bien
signalé qui vient encore de suède
c'est le fait que dans ce pays là le
congé il va être pris à la fois par le
père et par la mer ses papilles tout
pour la mère et si le père ne le prend
pas ces trois mois mais c'est perdu
tu ne veux pas être transféré à son
épouse sont donc 1
deuxième chose la garde des enfants
quand on fait des enfants ces contrats
si on n'a pas de garde si on n'a pas de
famille le moyen etc
c'est un peu difficile de retourner au
travail juste après deux crochets
maternité donc en et filles des systèmes
de garde d'accueil de garde des jeunes
enfants
l'oci l'europe a essayé de faire en
sorte que tous les pays mettent en place
des systèmes c'est ça vient doucement
mais ça en progrès et là aussi la france
a plutôt un aspect positif puisque le
taux de natalité en france est un des
meilleurs en europe avec l'irlande deux
enfants parce qu'en effet il ya des
systèmes de garde qui permettent aux
jeunes femmes de pouvoir avoir des
enfants et travailler et ça c'est très
considérable parce que souvent comme l'a
dit robin c'est les femmes ça tombe
enceinte est ce qu'on va les employés il
faut pas que la maternité soit un frein
à l'embauché envoyé quand on regarde en
matière politique
non j'ai pas fini je conclus je conclus
quand on regarde dans le domaine
politique le domaine économique le
domaine social
on voit que finalement en europe et
grâce à l'europe la cité sont des femmes
est plutôt mieux qu'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs elle est tellement mieux
qu'ailleurs peu de nombreuses autres
femmes regardent ce qui se passe en
europe est en vie un peu cette position
francs cette position européenne parce
qu'elles se disent mais s'ils y sont
arrivés eux sur ce vieux continent est
ce que nous on n'y arriverait pas est-ce
qu en effet cet exemple européen peut
être repris dans les autres parties du
monde
alors on le voit en afrique aux tuyaux
et souvent il ya en effet une
féminisation du parlement qui est de
plus en plus importante et on voit en
effet des pays qui affichent des taux
quasiment égaux à ceux de l'europe qui
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire anecdotes
moi je reçois la fondation beaucoup de
stagiaires étudiants venant
principalement des pays d'europe il
m'arrive d'en recevoir des russes des
américains et un jour j'ai eu une sud
coréenne et dans son rapport de stage il
y avait cette phrase de personnes
avaient mis jusqu'à présent mais dis moi
j'ai découvert l'europe qui aurait bien
venir y travailler parce que quatre
classes de la femme y est bien meilleure
que dans mon pays on parle de la corée
du sud la septième économie mondiale
celle qui fait trembler un peu certains
puissances occidentales eh bien oui en
effet encore est la situation de la
femme
et bien moi alors cette mixité
européenne est ce que c'est le paradis
sur terre je n'en sais rien mais je me
dis que si l'europe ça va pas très bien
en ce moment le monde non plus aidé
guerre il ya des crises il ya des
tensions et je ne crois pas que les
hommes seuls pourront relever tous les
défis qui s'imposent l'humanité elle est
composée d'hommes et de femmes est donc
cette mixité européenne c'est pas une
mixité affrontement c'est une mixité
on doit essayer de partager le pouvoir
parce que peut-être que si on se met
ensemble hommes et femmes pour relever
les défis
terra beaucoup mieux ce qui se passe
actuellement l'objet d'une proposition
complètement iconoclaste est-ce que les
affaires du monde ne marcherait pas
mieux si en effet il est davantage de
femmes au pouvoir et je viens de me
rendre compte que finalement ce n'était
pas une proposition aussi le nôtre parce
que ça parce que la magazine cette
semaine titre elles font bouger le monde
merci
[Musique]